ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ทุกๆคนทุกคนถึงบนฝนต้นค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนเอ้อเย้ก็ก็ตอนนี้ก็มาเจอกับเรา 2
คนนะครูหญิงนะคะแล้วก็ลูกป่าช้าๆ
ในวีดีโอบีกินเนอร์เอ้อใช่ไหมมีกินเนอะ
อันครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะค่ะวันนี้วันเสาร์วัน
เสาร์ที่ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์ที่ 22
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
คำคม
ตีผชอะไรคะตีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์วันศุกร์
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่
21 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์
ที่เท่ากไก่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 23 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะวันนี้ก็วันเสาร์เนาะแล้วตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น
11:00 นกี่นาทีคะ
11 โมง 47 นาทีค่ะ 40  47 นาทีก็เป็นตอน
กลางวันเนาะ
เวลากลางวัน
แล้ว
พี่วันนี้เป็นไงบ้างผู้หญิงสบายดีดีค่ะ
ครูบาโป้ขา
รูปฟ้าสบายดีค่ะโอเคดีมากค่ะครูฟ้าเพราะ
ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงและก็จะมีเกมให้ครู
ฟ้าแล้วก็นักเรียนแบบต้องแบบเดาว่าอะไร
หา
ชายห่า
ชายเดี๋ยวเราเดี๋ยวคุยเองขอ Share  screen
ก่อนนะคะครูฟ้าอาจจะใช้เวลาซักซักพัก
หนึ่งช่วงพงษ์ใส่เหรอ
Green  Chair กรีนเฮ้าส์อันนี้กำลัง
Green  Sharing นะจ่ายค่ะมาหรือยังครับ
มาแล้ว
แล้ววิอะไรคะเนี่ยครูหญิงเห็นไหมผู้หญิง
ก็จะเล็ดมีรูปหนอน 1  2  3  3 รูปนะคะมี
ทั้งหมดเนี่ยเป็น Action ใช่ไหมเป็น verb
นะคะก็อย่างข้อที่ 1 ข้อที่ไหนกันเนี้ย
รูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 เนี่ยทั้งหมด
แล้วนะคะก็คือดูเนาะตาใช่ไหมตาแล้วก็ดู
ไม่รู้ที่ 1 ก็ดูรูปที่ 2 ก็ดูรูปที่ 3
ก็ดูนะคะคำถามนะคำถามก็คือ
รูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 รูปไหนดูทีวี
มือ
นักเรียนคิดว่ารูปไหนดูทีวีคะ
1  2  3  4  1  5 โอเค
มีใครให้เวลานักเรียน 5 วินาทีไงคิดๆ
input
สายครูฟ้ารู้อยู่แล้วใช่ไหมคะรูปฟ้ารูป
ที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 รูปไหนดูทีวีกู
รูรู้นะ
นี่ฮะรูปที่ดูทีวีนะคะดูดูทีวีก็คือรูป
ที่ 2 ห่างโรคที่ 2 เนาะดูทีวีแล้วรูปที่
1 ดูอะไร
รูปที่ 1 เนี่ยดูหนัง
Spiderman  Batman ดูหนังแล้วรูปที่ 3
ดูอะไรคะรูป
R3 ดูคอนเสิร์ตค่ะ
ดูคอนเสิร์ตเนาะ
อันต่อไปข้อที่สองนะคะข้อที่ 2
ข้อที่สองเนี่ยก็คือดื่มใช่ไหมดื่มนะทั้ง
หมดเนี่ยนะคะรูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3
เนี่ยเดิมนะเดิมนะคะ
คำถามนะคะรูปไหน
ดื่มกาแฟ
โว้โอโอ้โห
2  2  3  3  4  4  5 หมดเวลา
รูปไหนดื่มกาแฟรุปที่ 1
ไร่แล้วหรือว่าลูกพี่เอ
มีรูปพูดเวลาแล้วนักเรียนเนี่ยต้องตอบ
แล้วเสร็จแล้วอ่ะครูฟ้ารู้หายดื่มกาแฟ
รูปพี่ 1  5
รูปที่ 1 กาแฟแล้วรูปที่ 2 ดื่มอะไร
รูปที่ 2 ดื่มนมมีลูกที่ 3 ดื่มอะไร
รูปที่ 3 ดื่มชาชาชั้นองค์สนมศาสตร์ครู
ฟ้าดื่มกาแฟดื่มนมดื่มชาครูฟ้าชอบดื่ม
อะไร
ครูฟ้าชอบดื่มชานมหา
รูปที่ 3 ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าใสอ่ะ
ชอบดูชานมผู้สาวผู้หญิงล่ะคะครูหญิงรูป
ที่ 1 ค่ะดื่มกาแฟ
ครูหญิงชอบกาแฟ
สายน้องอ่างข้อที่ 3 นะหาข้อต่อไปนะ
รูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 เนี่ยทั้งหมด
ก็คือเล่นนะฮะกำลังเล่นอยู่ใช่ไหมคะอ่า
เหมือนครูหญิงมีโทรศัพท์เล่นโทรศัพท์สมัย
เล่นโทรศัพท์
เล่นคู่ฟ้าเล่นเกมคอมพิวเตอร์เกมได้ไหม
เล่นเกมอ่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นเล่นเหมือนกันเนาะ
รูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 ลูกไหนเล่น
ฟุตบอล
เมื่อนักเรียนคิดว่ารูปไหนเล่นฟุตบอล We
Are นักรัก 1  2
3  4
[เพลง]
rarm41 ขำฮ่าๆ
ไหมแล้วรูปที่ 2 เล่นอะไรรูปที่ 2 รูปที่
2 เล่นของเล่น
รถจะเป็นของเล่น
รูปที่ 3 เล่นอะไร
รูปที่ 3 เล่นตุ๊กตา
ตุ๊กตาตุ๊กตาครูฟ้าก็เล่นตุ๊กตา
ของเล่นตุ๊กตา
ครูฟ้าช่อตุ๊กตา
น้อง
ต่อไปข้อต่อไปนะคะรูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูป
ที่ 3 เนี่ยขับมาๆทั้งหมดเนี่ยขับอ่าคำ
ถามนักเรียนคิดว่ารูปไหนขับรถ
ขับรถนะคะ
ได้ค่ะ
หนึ่ง
สอง
สามสี่
ห้าหน้าหมดเวลา
ครูฟ้าคะรูปไหนขับรถคะ
รูปที่ขับรถก็คือ
หมู่ที่ 3 ค่ะ
รบที่ 3 ขับรถแล้วรูปที่ 1 ขับอะไร
รูปที่ 1 ขับเรืออันนี้เป็นเรือเนาะแล้ว
รูปที่ 2 ขับอะไร
รูปที่ 2 ขับเครื่องบินจังหวะนี้เป็น
เครื่องบินเนอะอ่ารูปที่ 1 เรือขับเรือ
รูปที่ 2 เครื่องบินขับเครื่องบินรูปที่ 3
รถก็ขับรถนะคะไม่รู้นักเรียนเนี่ยต้องตอบ
ถูกหรือเปล่าอ่ะหาข้อจิตต่อไปนะคะรูปที่ 1
รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 เนี่ยก็คือเฟิร์สเนาะ
เปิดนะคะ
ทางหมดเนี่ยเปิดอา
มีคำเธอถามนะคะนักเรียนคิดว่ารูปไหน
เปิดไฟ
ไปก็ฝนใช่ไหมอยู่ข้างบน
1  2
3  4
บทเวลาครูฟ้าคะรูปหน้าไหน
เปิดไฟท์
รูปที่เปิดไปก็คือ
รูปที่
ของค่าาารูปที่ 2 เปิดไฟน้องแล้วรูปที่ 1
เปิดอะไร
รู้พี่หนึ่งเปิดประตู
ก็จะเปิดประตูแล้วรูปที่ 3 เปิดอะไร
รู้ที่ 3 เปิดน้ำค่ะอ้าเปิดน้ำเนาะเปิด
ประตูเปิดไฟแล้วก็เปิดน้ำอาหาร
ข้อต่อไป
ก็ต่อไปเนาะรูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3
เนาะทั้งหมดก็คือล้างล้างฆ่าล้างอ่ะอ่ะ
ช้ำถามนะคะ
รูปไหน
ล้างมื้อ
หลังมือ
อ่ะมือ
3  4
A45  R หมดเวลา
ครูฟ้าคะรูปไหนล้างมื้อ
ที่ล้างมือนะคะก็คือรูปที่ 2 ค่ะ
ถ่ายรูปที่ 2 คิดว่าถ้านักเรียนอยู่
ประเทศไทยน่าจะได้ยินบ่อยๆเนอะล้างมือ
ล้างมือ
ตอนนี้ไม่ต้องล้างมืออ่ะแล้วโรคที่หนึ่ง
ล้างอะไร
รูปที่ 1 ล้างจานค่ะใจหาตรงนี้ก็คือจาน
อาจารย์บางจานรูปที่ 3 ล้างอะไร
รู้ที่ 3 ล้างหน้าอาร้านๆเมื่อล้างหน้า
หมู่บ้านรูปฟ้าร้านอาหาร
ล้างมือล้างหน้ารุฟ้าชอบล้างอะไรคะล้าง
เบื่อ
กุมภาล้างมือ
เยอะมากนะล้างมือแล้ว
ร้านจานเนื้อลูกที่ 1 เนี่ยร้านจานผู้ค้า
ชอบไหมคะไม่อ่ะ
ไม่ชอบร้านชายครูฟ้านะบอกก็ล้างมือล้าง
มือแล้วครูฟ้าล้างมือล้างมือเนี่ยใช้เวลา
นานไหม
ไม่หาไม่คู่ปาก 1  2  3  4  5  7  7  5
และ
อ่ะต่อไป
มาต่อไปนะคะพี่ผู้ชายเนี่ยรูปที่ 1 รูป
ที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 เนี่ยทั้งสามรูปเนาะเป็น
ผู้ชายเนาะผู้ชายรูปที่ 1 ผู้ชายรูปที่ 2
ผู้ชายรูปที่ 3 เนี่ยยืนใช่ไหมเขายืนอยู่
มาเย็นราคา
[เพลง]
คำถามคำถามนัดเรียนคิดว่ารูปไหนที่ผู้ชาย
เนี่ย
ยืนเท้าเอว
ยางหรือเปล่าโอ๊ย
หาเวลยืนเท้าเอว
เอว
4  5
งาหมดเวลา
ช่วงเวลาอันนี้จ๋านักเรียนอะต้องคิดคิด
นิดนึงนะคะครูฟ้าคะรูปไหนที่ผู้ชายเนี่ย
ยืนเท้าเอว
รูปที่ผู้ชายยืนเท้าเอวก็คือรูปที่ 3 ฮะ
ค่ะสมัย
โน้นตรงนี้นะคะตรงนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าเอว
นอนเอวหรือผู้ชายในเอามือแล้วก็น้องยืน
เท้าเอวแล้วรูปที่ 1 ยืนทำอะไรคะ
ยืนกอดอก
สมัยก่อนปลุกแล้วรูปที่ 2 ยืนอะไร
ยืนยงใจ
ยืนน่ะ
ยกมือดีใจ
ดีใจหนาก็ได้ดีค่ะน้องกะนิรูปที่ 1 ยืน
กอด oak รูปที่ 2 ยืนดีใจรูปที่ 3 ยืน
เท้าเอวยืนเท้าเดียว
ได้ is ท้ายแล้วนะคะคิดว่าเนาะๆอันนี้
แหละรูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2 รูปที่ 3 นะคะทั้ง
หมดเนี่ยก็คือขี่หน้าเป็นการฉีดนะคะ
สายรักครูฟ้าคะรูปแบบไม่ใช่กูฟ้าค่ะนัด
เรียนคำถามเนาะนักเรียนคิดว่ารูปไหนเนี่ย
ฉีดยา
[เพลง]
หญ้าโอ้ย rov
อ่ะ 1  2
เอาของ
ป๋าม
rarm41 ยา
รูปที่ฉีดยาก็คือ
รูปพี่เขียนไม่ได้ 3 อย่างอาอารูปที่ 3
เนาะว่ามีพยาบาลใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีเด็กแล้ว
ก็อันนี้ก็คือเข็มฉีดยาสมัยแล้วก็พยาบาล
กี่ที่ต้นแขนคิดว่านักเรียนครูหญิงครูฟ้า
ปีที่แล้ว
2021 ทุกคนนะจะจีบเหมือนกันนะฉีดวัคซีน
ฉีดวัคซีนฉีดยานะคะแล้วรูปที่ 1 มีขีด
อะไร
ฉีดน้ำค่ะ
นิสงกรานต์
ฉีดน้ำแล้วรูปที่ 2 ฉีดอะไร
ฉีดโบท็อก
นี้เป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีเข็มแล้ว
ก็ฉีดน้ำผู้หญิงแบบก็ฉีดโบท็อกก็คือ
เลยค่ะ Before  After ใช่ไหม 4 ก็เป็น
รูปฉีดนะคะก็จะมีที่นักเรียนเล่นเกมเค้า
จะมีอันนี้เป็นดูเอ้อดูอะขาเนี่ยอะไรคะ
คือฟ้า
ดื่มค่ะอันนี้อะไรคะเล่น
อันนี้อะไรคะขับอ๋อ
คะอันนี้อะไรคะเปิด
อันนี้อะไรคะล้างขา
อันนี้อะไรคะ
ยืนน้องยืนสุดท้ายอดี้อะไรคะ
ฉีด 5  4 ใช่ไหมคะก็เป็น
ทำ Action เนาะดีวันนี้มาเรามาเล่นเกมกับ
นักเรียนนะคะไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนเนี้ยถูก
กี่ข้อพิมพ์พ่อก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเขาได้นะคะ
วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายเงินสดไว้ก่อน